sans transition nous revenons à
l'actualité en ce moment même à
l'assemblée se discute l'aménagement de
la loi sur le monopole de la télévision
et de la radio diffusion en france c'est
un sujet qui provoque de vives réactions
depuis la multiplication des radios
pirates ou si vous préférez les radios
libres
ces radios là elle devrait subir des
sanctions encore plus grave
si le projet qui est discuté cet après
midi est votée par l'assemblée
voici en train d'émettre clandestinement
l'une des 80 radio pirate libre locale
l'une de ces radios partis à l'assaut
d'un bastion célèbre le monopole de
l'autre côté de votre transistors à
modulation de fréquence vous écoutez
génération en 2000 sur 96 mégahertz et
en stéréo génération en 2000 est une
station de radio locale et indépendant
le monopole en radio cela veut dire que
seul l'état le droit d'émettre le
monopole date de 1942 et la dernière
lois qui le réglementent est une loi de
74 en grande bretagne ce monopole a
disparu en 72 et une vingtaine de
stations commerciales soumises à des
contrats strict cohabitent avec les
stations locales de la bbc
aux etats unis en amérique du sud pas de
monopole non plus en italie il ait été
supprimée en 76 la création d'un millier
de petites radios locales a conduit à
une sorte d'anarchie cacophonique que
redoute le gouvernement français les
partisans de l'aménagement du monopole
utilise surtout un argument
la liberté d'expression doit être
entière et non pas étatisée mais liberté
d'expression pour faire quoi
une radio politique ou une radio
commerciale comme ici une sorte de
petite radio périphérique avec de la
publicité
on préfère être inféodé s'il faut l'être
à des annonceurs qui seront multiples
donc il nous laisse la possibilité d'un
choix plutôt qu'à une préfecture
municipalité voir un parti politique
voire à une année riche et quelconque
le seul point commun entre génération
2000 et radio 93 ici en pleine émission
c'est d'être poursuivis en justice
tout le reste est différent radio 93
fonctionne avec dix mille francs de
matériel contre 1 millions de francs en
génération 2000 ici pas de publicité
mais une sorte de happening de quartier
une conversation entre les animateurs et
les habitants du voisinage
une radio qui correspondrait à ce qu'on
appelle le besoin de communication pour
eux même si le monopole subsistent il
faut l'aménager
il y aura de la place pour tout le monde
dans le cadre d'une loi de nouvelles on
pense qu'on a intérêt ou effectivement à
chercher des alliances bond par rapport
à toutes les radios par un local qui a
accepté l'existence des radios libres
sans ambiguïté nous sommes d'accord
effectivement un président d'alliance
à l'assemblée le débat est une bataille
juridique autour du code des ptt et de
la loi de 74 et chacun a son idée
le pc pour une radio municipale le ps
pour un meilleur service public
le rpr est en majorité pour le maintien
du monopole une partie de l'udf
également le monopole sera bien défendus
par les parlementaires
we know